[Music]
I'm Keith Olbermann and this is the
resistance there are new hints that Bob
Muller may be approaching the endgame on
Trump and Russia as charlottesville and
Trump's suicidal news conference and the
whitewashing of the Nazis and racists
and the North Korea Bluff and the Bannon
austere and Afghanistan and all of it
swirled in the kaleidoscope of this
increasingly unbelievable Trump quote
presidency unquote this came out of
nowhere
prediction just in from top Republican
strategist trump resigns quote once
Muller closes in on him and the family
pence makes Rubio VP GOP recovers well I
don't know about the GOP recovers part
unless they expect Trump to resign like
tomorrow but the rest of it is
fascinating especially the identity of
the reporter who tweeted it I have known
John Harwood for 14 years
he was the White House correspondent
than the chief political correspondent
for The Wall Street Journal I used to
put him on countdown all the time for a
decade he has been the chief Washington
correspondent for CNBC he moderated a
GOP debate in 2015 they whined about him
of course
Harwood plays stuff very close to the
vest even though he was in a Bobby
Kennedy ad as a kid we used to consider
him a small C conservative kind of
reporter trump resigns once Muller
closes in on him and the family that
tweet is very unlike John Harwood now
Harwood source could be very wrong but
he is not a lone voice in this
wilderness no less a figure than Carl
Bernstein dropped these important
Republicans conservatives Intel military
high ups increasingly saying in private
that Trump is unfit to be President
because of lack of ethics competence
temperament stability reporters should
find out how pervasive such talk may be
so what does any of this have to do with
the Special Counsel Robert Muller and
his investigation of Trump and Russia
well this the National Enquirer so pro
Trump that Trump himself claimed that
Joe Scarborough called him to stop a
story in it oversold some gossip about
the former Trump campaign
and Paul Manafort one of trumps trusted
advisors was bedding another woman
behind his wife's back betraying her and
his country well how did we go from
Trump resigns once Muller closes in on
him and the family to the National
Enquirer again returned to a small C
conservative reporter Paul wood world
affairs correspondent for the BBC
writing in the British magazine The
Spectator why now a hit piece on the one
man Trump surely must need to keep on
side than the Russia investigation one
answer mana Ford has been flipped
reports in US publications say it was
mana Ford who told the FBI about a
meeting between Trump's eldest son
Donald Jr and a Russian lawyer linked to
the Kremlin that would be terrible news
for the president if true the FBI's
investigation into alleged collusion
between the Trump campaign and Russia
now being assisted by the manager of
that campaign yeah it would the bbc's
man also quotes an intelligence
community source who says the amount of
overheard Kremlin conversations quote
about the relationship between team
Trump and Moscow plus the number of
quote direct contacts between Trump's
people and various Russians have been
underestimated there are quote dozens
and reporter wood also notes that it may
not just be manna Ford helping Muller to
build the case against Trump and Russia
there's also one time FBI informant and
one time Trump business associate the
Russian born Felix a turd for several
weeks there have been rumors that seder
is ready to rat again agreeing to help
Muller would rights in the spectator
quote he has told family and friends he
knows he and POTUS are going to prison
someone talking to mothers investigators
informed me Seder and mana Fork together
would pose a deadly threat to Trump's
presidency if they testify that Russian
money in his businesses led to
information being exchanged with Russian
intelligence yeah they would not just a
conspiracy with the Russians to swing
our election but money changing hands as
well and there are literally almost a
dozen other small stories it could bring
us back to the scenario posited by John
Harwood
source the New York Times report that
Muller has linked one of the Russians at
the Trump jr. mana Fort Kushner meeting
in June 2016 to Russian intelligence and
two allies of Vladimir Putin that
low-level Trump campaign staffer who
left an email trail a mile wide
suggesting and offering face-to-face
meetings with Putin the Ukrainian
computer geek who wrote some of the
malware with which the russians hacked
the Democratic National Committee
turning himself in and becoming an FBI
witness the FBI raiding mana for its
home at the crack of dawn and then
slamming him with subpoenas about his
banking records and those of his
companies Trump's crazy self
contradictory statement about the steel
dossier quote Russia spent a lot of
money on that false report and that was
Russian money and I think it was
Democrat money to Trump's sleazy
attorney John Dowd admitting Trump quote
appreciates what Bob Muller is doing he
asked me to share that with him and
that's what I've done the president has
sent messages back and forth and another
New York Times reports that quote Muller
is in talks with the West Wing about
interviewing current and former senior
administration officials including the
recently ousted White House chief of
staff
Reince Priebus interviewing them about
the firing of James Comey an
investigation which alone could produce
a stack of counts of obstruction of
justice that could be fatal to the trump
presidency even if nothing concrete is
ever proven about Russia itself and
there is also a note in that time story
that quote mr. Priebus appears on the
calendar of Paul Manafort on the same
day in June 2016 that mr. manna fort and
other campaign officials including mr.
Trump's eldest son and son-in-law
attended a meeting with Russians who
claimed to have damaging information
about Hillary Clinton according to two
people briefed on the matter for a while
now I have thought the Trump presidency
will end suddenly on Wednesday June 21st
1998 I was in Los Angeles to do a week
of celebrity filled MSNBC shows
previewing NBC's coverage of the
football Super Bowl that Sunday we were
on the kitchen set of the
a series third Rock from the Sun and I
was waiting to go live with its star the
great actor John Lithgow behind me was a
refrigerator with refrigerator magnets
on it they constituted two apples and a
banana the producer who is now the
president of MSNBC suddenly walks up to
me right before air time and says slight
change of plans buddy new lead story
you'll be doing the talk back from
Washington with Tim Russert because the
president may have to resign tonight
then we'll do lifts go on tape in the C
and D blocks out of habit I nodded and
then I realized what had actually just
said and I responded wait a minute
would you repeat that and he said we'll
do lifts go on tape and the C and D
blocks and I said no no the part before
that this was of course the Clinton
Lewinsky story and it was breaking that
suddenly and unexpectedly and for weeks
now I have been anticipating that
Trump's last day in office will dawn
like all the others and then around
dinnertime it'll suddenly break that he
is about to resign I don't know if
that's next Tuesday or next year but I
think whenever it is that is what it
will feel like prediction just in from
top Republican strategist Trump resigns
quote once Muller closes in on him and
the family would that work for you yeah
it would resist remove peace